Over buddy, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's again going over genetic pathways.
This is what you would receive when you do your 23 and me.
You do not get this information directly from 23 and me.
We need to take the raw data off and put it in our software.
So again, if you're catching this video on YouTube, you would not see this data unless you had software
to put it in to be able to pull up from your raw data and your gene steps.
What exactly is going on?
This section of this giant report here has to do with the Matiety cycle.
That cycle would be on a pathway planner like this.
So from the folate pathway from a previous video, you produce methyl tetrahedral folate right here
that feeds in through the MTR gene, recycles B12 through the MTRR gene and eventually produces
methionine, goes through the MAT gene to produce your main methyl donor.
And remember the main methyl donation purpose is to turn genes on and off.
So important that you produce methyl donors through multiple different streams and different pathways.
So if this was completely blocked, you kind of have some failsafe methods so you don't die.
But this pathway right here is very important.
This gene right here that we spoke about on the last video is probably the most researched and talked about gene.
There's even Facebook, MTHFR, Facebook groups because it's so important.
Well, it's not any more important than any of these other little bubble genes here.
They're all just as important. It's just misunderstood.
The MTRR and the MTRR gene recycle B12 and along with some other genes, your FUT2 genes down here is how you absorb B12.
Your gastric intrinsic factor genes, how you make intrinsic factor, that's essential for absorbing B12.
Your TCN genes are how you transport B12.
So you look at this person, they have no defect on their MTR gene.
Well, that's really good.
And they have a single allele defect on their MTRR gene.
Oh, that's not so great.
But they got to mess for other factors as far as need for B12.
So this person right here, I would definitely recommend B12.
And what type of B12?
You have the cheapo-synthetic B12 called cyanobetwelf, cyanobethiety.
Nobody should really take that.
You have methylcomolamine.
Is that something you should take methylcomolamine?
Well, it depends.
So methylcomolamine might be a good pick for this person, but you have to go down and look at the neurotransmitters too.
This person's got all these mild defects, really bad mild defects.
If you give this person too many methyl groups, I need to give them B12.
So I'm going to give them methylcomolamine, I heard that's the best one.
You're going to push that biopterid pathway and you're going to push serotonin.
You're going to have a whole mess of mood issues, mood disorders,
anger, frustration, depression.
You don't want to do that.
So I would absolutely not recommend on this person a methyl B12.
I'd use a hydroxy or an adenosylcomolamine form of B12 for this person.
So this is definitely a need for B12 for this person.
This could be, we spoke about tiredness and fatigue when we talk about the mitochondrial genes,
but this is another huge thing for tiredness and fatigue.
This is a B12, anemia case right here.
So you want to support that the right way.
All right, I hope that helps and we'll continue with other videos.
Thanks.